hey everybody we got to freak out about
the Doctor Who finale you might be a
doctor but I am the doctor or the
original you might say so just careful
for spoilers from the episode we'll talk
about the Christmas special too I
wondered what the doctors final words
would be I don't want to go but we know
now that he's going to be part of the
Christmas special they announced a big
comic-con panel it'll be like his
farewell panel where they'll give way to
whoever the new doctor is going to be so
presumably we'll find out who that is
either at the end of the Christmas
special or at the beginning of the first
episode of Christian Bulls run a series
11 so let's just do top 10 WTF like I
normally do we'll shout out Easter eggs
there was a whole bunch of stuff
especially that moment is the end which
i think is a reference to one of the
early lost episodes of Doctor Who with
William Hartnell called Marco Polo he
was one of the episodes that was part of
that story the story was called Marco
Polo but the episode where he's in this
snowy area I think is called the roof of
the world and that was just one of the
earliest Lost episodes of Doctor Who but
number 10 the creepy reveal of the upper
level with Bill and the doctor so you
have this big saga of Bill they
flashback to number 9 the two masters
just getting it on with each other there
was this weird psychosexual thing going
on between the two of them Missy had her
together through the episode
because she's come to that big arc where
now she's on Team dr. but the master
isn't having any of it so he just as
evil as he's ever been so John Simm did
a fantastic job of making you hate that
character again but you love to hate him
he did an amazing job so I loved the
character but you're meant to hate him
so they did as many things as they could
through the episode to make him feel
irredeemable so you would cheer his
eventual death and I love the way they
ended that character too we were always
heading for this no we were always
heading for this shooting ourselves in
the back but I was really happy with the
way they treated Bill's character so
number 8 the doctor turns the Cybermen
on them with Missy and Bill's help
so inadvertently it seemed like Missy
was helping him even if she wasn't
actually trying to help him but it was a
great setup for Bill's arc during the
episode because even though you're
pretty sure that she's not going to be
fixed the doctor even admits to it you
know I'm not lying when I said that I've
tried to fix you but he's also honest
with
bill when he says that they're probably
not going to be able to get out of it so
it takes her a while to come to terms
with her own death and the doctor as
well because he slowly starts
regenerating through the course of the
episode but number seven that WTF reveal
where they show her and you're like oh
my god she's fixed but then you see the
mirror and you learned you've been
seeing this from bills perspective for
the whole episode so they play with the
camera in really funny ways I actually
like the way they did that because
normally you're watching an episode of
Doctor Who and the doctor is the main
protagonist so you're viewing it through
him but then you see bill with the
shadows like she sees the shadow of the
Cybermen helmet number six the Cybermen
are coming so it turns into the Alamo
they even have some spaghetti western
music it feels like Ennio Morricone like
they know that they're going to die at
least the doctor knows that he's going
to die but he's going to make a last
stand and save as many people as he can
so it was a great rollout I love the way
they explained the time-dilation field
so it gives the classic Mondas Cybermen
time to create the newer versions of the
reboot Cybermen so you probably picked
up that there was a lot of stuff going
back to the first doctor we literally
saw him during the episode so they did a
good job of mixing the really classic
stuff going back to the beginning and
doing the modern stuff too but number 5
was the doctors staying with me speech
he explains to Missy and the master that
I don't do what I do to win it's not
about winning it's about doing what's
right and about being kind the doctor
had a lot of great lines during the
episode a lot of really classic moments
but this was probably the best speech
where it's meant to be this big call to
action and I love the way that John
sends master responds to it this is the
face of the person that didn't hear
anything you just said in the way that
Michelle Gomez was playing her character
through the whole episode was great
because you feel like the look in her
eye means that she has some secret plan
that she hasn't revealed yet even though
she's feigning that she's not on the
doctors side so it was a nice twist when
they both tried to bail and she says no
sorry not going to happen but number 4
welcome to the sisterhood I love the way
they play with their time loop because
you know that he has to get away so that
he can regenerate into her so they have
to explain how that happened but then
when she says it was always heading
towards this us standing with the doctor
he isn't having it at all and kills her
in Michelle Gomez did say this would be
her last series so she's not going to
surprise
during series 11 but that's not the end
of the master character doctor who
breaks all of its own rules all the time
so there will be a master at some point
in the future but because Moffat waited
so long to bring the character back and
we saw them come back in such a big way
with the John Simm version of the
character it just feels like they're not
going to go straight to the master in
series 11 or even series 12 so it'll
probably be a while before we see them
again but number three this actually
turned out to be setup but it was a
great line I am NOT a doctor I am the
doctor the original you might say
doctors are not required and even though
I knew about the Christmas special he
kept regenerating during the episode and
I kept wondering how they were going to
address that but I love the way they
ended it so number two I'd hoped there
be stars is a great way to go out but we
know now that that's not his last line
so bill says her goodbyes and I actually
really like the way they ended her
character because even if that organic
water based ship is just totally crazy
in Opie it explains that it can
rearrange matter so it absorbs her and
she becomes like it so they go off on
their adventures hopefully I'll see you
again it's a big universe so I actually
did not know it was going to be her last
episode but it makes sense if Capaldi
was going to stay on for one more season
they'd bring on a companion and they
wouldn't try to do the Clara thing where
they overlap an old companion with a new
doctor they'll just start completely
fresh with whoever the new companion is
going to be when the new doctor debuts
but then of course you know number one
big twist at the end he steps out into
the snow you don't know where you are
he refuses to regenerate no I don't want
to go too many phases I'm the doctor no
no no that just sounds silly you might
be a doctor but I am the doctor the
original you might say so I don't know
exactly what the story for the Christmas
special is going to be but obviously
it's meant to eulogize the doctor and
give him a big grand send-off in a
hopeful way using his first phase to
remind him why he went on this journey
in the first place so there were lots of
big callbacks to things that Capaldi
said earlier this series like they
brought the water ship back he talked
about when he and the master were back
on Gallifrey they promised each other
that they visit each of the stars in the
sky so that's why I really love that
line of his
I'd hope there be stars but overall I
felt like it was a great episode maximum
cry they really wanted to send off the
characters to like let you know that
they were definitely going to be dying
but do it in a way that left them a back
door for the future like bill could
always pop back up in the future if they
want to bring her back but there's just
so much good character work in this they
could have expanded this by another 20
minutes and turned it into like a
special all by itself so let me know in
the comments what was your favorite
moment there were a lot of references to
previous Cybermen episodes like he says
Mondas Telos planet 14 Kili re Worf
they're all battles that he's fought the
Cybermen and won before and I love the
idea that he said that anywhere there's
people there will always be Cybermen
that just the direction people are
headed you put people and technology
together it all winds up going to the
same place so the next time you pull out
your smartphone you'll probably give it
a double-take but really excited about
the Christmas special it'll be
interesting to see what they change for
series 11 I don't know who the new
doctor is but it does sound like they're
going with someone younger because
they've done the old professor so now
like the most different thing they could
do would be to go back to young so like
late 20-something early 30-something
Doctor maybe David Tennant aged so let
me know in the comments who do you think
the new doctor is but what will happen
is is of course I'll do a video for the
Christmas special when it drops later
this year if they do announce who the
new doctor is at Comic Con I'll do a
video for that too that's only going to
be in a couple weeks so it's happening
right around the corner
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get everything but while
you wait for everything you can click
here for brand new Rick and Morty and
you can click here for my spider-man
homecoming review thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you